con la inauguración de la embajada de
honduras hoy en jerusalén ya son cuatro
los países que han abierto las puertas
de sus legaciones en la capital israelí
capitalidad que es puesta en cuestión
por la mayor parte de la comunidad
internacional y que por ello mantienen
sus embajadas en la ciudad de tel aviv
la inauguración esta mañana fue solemne
pero feliz alegre en la que una gran
delegación hondureña presidida por el
presidente juan orlando hernández y
compuesta por muchos pastores
evangelistas fue recibida por el
presidente israelí reuvén rivlin en uno
de sus últimos actos públicos porque
deja el cargo también por el primer
ministro israelí naftalí bennett y por
el ministro de exteriores y a ir la vida
todos ellos felicitaron a hernández por
este paso valiente dijeron también
firmaron un acuerdo de cooperación
bilateral que engloba cuestiones
agrarias acuíferas comerciales y también
de seguridad